la chronique de l'écho avec ce sujet
l'intelligence économique à l'is alors
oui tout à fait alors j'ai emplettes au
benoît de saint sernin bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes les directeurs et le
cofondateur de l'école européenne de
l'intelligence économique est basé à
versailles en la première raison qu'est
ce que l'intelligence économique
car avant de vous laisser répondre on va
écouter les saint quentinois on est allé
interroger aujourd'hui on va voir
retrouver un peu collé par la question
par garde que le gouvernement gère
correctement son état et d'autre part
que tout le monde soit sur le même pied
d'égalité du travail pour tous de
préférence et qui est pas autant de
retraités qui soit la rue en train de
faire la mendicité la gestion la bonne
gestion jedir est l'expression les
familles affamées familiar parce que je
l'entends par exemple aux informations
souvent mais je serais incapable de vous
la définir de façon claire ne pas
dépenser plus que ce que l'on gagne par
exemple un exemple parmi tant d'autres
c'est de faire des économies quand ça va
pas bien et doit distribuer quand ça va
mieux je trouve un juste équilibre ainsi
de faire attention de faire le pour le
contre de compte et puis de voir ce qui
va le mieux
on la meilleure façon possible de gérer
ce qu'on a dans son porte monnaie est ce
qu'on sort de son porte monnaie
il faut savoir bien gérer
pas faire trop de dépenses comme nous
d'ailleurs
et bien c'est avoir une économie en
fonction des gens et non pas de l'argent
venant de saint sernin on entend bien
gérer son argent est ce que c'est
l'école que vous avez créé par nettement
on gère bien l'argent oui on invite les
entreprises à bien gérer l'argent mais
dans la définition de l'intelligence
économique se résume à trois verbes
c'est savoir se protéger
savoir se renseigner et savoir influencé
donc on forme des cadres d'entreprises
ou des jeunes à ces trois notions je me
protège je me renseigne et je cherchais
influence et ça s'adresse pas à monsieur
madame tout le monde pour gérer son
budget non sert à ça on est bien
d'accord que monsieur madame tout le
monde et à se protéger quand même
surtout avec toute la cyber délinquance
aujourd'hui les vols d'identité des
personnes etc
ça ce sont des éléments de protection
qui rentre dans le spectre de
l'intelligence économique mais relier
les élèves sont des cadres mais aussi
des étudiants puisqu'il ya un
partenariat avec l'université de
versailles saint quentin vous proposait
notamment de master 1 l'an protection de
l'entreprise et l'autre professionnel
d'intelligence économique et de
développement comment se sont mis en
place ces masters et puis parlez nous de
ces étudiants aussi qui sont une partie
du temps à l'université puis l'autre
partie à versailles chez vous voilà en
fait ya effectivement deux catégories
d'étudiants il ya les jeunes ceux qu'on
appelle les jeunes cons 23 25 ans qui
sortent d'écoles de commerce ou par
exemple d'universités dont celle de
versailles et puis des gens qui
souviennent des services de l'état ou
qui viennent des entreprises est en fait
là le principe de notre école c'est que
les élèves en cours une partie du temps
et l'autre partie ils ne mènent que des
vraies missions d'intelligence
économique qui sont commandées par des
entreprises
on est ce qu'on appelle une école
professionnalisantes ce que vous avez
appris à l'école vous le mettez tout de
suite en pratique pour de vrai on
imagine que c'est assez secret on
al'impression intelligence économique
est ce que vous pouvez me donner un
exemple démission alors par exemple dans
l'émission les dont on peut parler ya
les missions de protection
donc on est d'une entreprise à définir
ce qu elle doit protéger et comment le
protéger
on a ensuite les missions de
renseignement on va à la collecte
un peu comme vous les journalistes de
l'information disponible que l'on va
n'ont pas donné à nos lecteurs ou à nos
téléspectateurs comme ce soir mais de la
donner aux dirigeants d'entreprises qui
nous l'ont demandé
donc ce sont des missions de rang
iman alors effectivement il ya souvent
dans notre métier une part de
confidentialité et un petit côté james
bond c'est non alors james bond
utilisent des moyens illégaux ce qui
n'est pas notre cas salut bande à dumas
galal ronfler comparaison est flatteuse
c'est une demande en augmentation de la
part des entreprises on pense avec
l'arrivée des nouvelles technologies
oui alors en fait c'est même plus que ça
c'est une demande en explosion parce que
c'est un peu une tarte à la crème et
tout ce qui est mondialisation et autres
ont fait que nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui à des gens qui ont un
rapport à la notion de l'information
très différent de nous dans nos écoles
qu'elles aient été d'ingénieurs de
commerce de journalisme août on n'a pas
appris la valeur de l'information
or ce que veulent nos adversaires
aujourd'hui si nous voler cette
information est malheureusement
malheureusement il y arrive souvent fait
très qu elle est unique en france pour
l'instant alors sur ce format là oui
elle est unique mais il ya plusieurs
formations d'intelligence économique en
france si on a à peu près 4 5 de valeur
mais c'est la seule la nôtre est la
seule qui délivre un titre d'état
d'intelligence économique et surtout la
seule qui à ce mode pédagogique avec les
vraies missions écoles européennes y est
temps d antenne en europe
oui et une antenne principale à
bruxelles et on accueille évidemment
dans le cadre de l'école des étudiants
européens avant de fonder cette école
vous vous travaillez dans un grand
groupe redman marne la vallée en trompe
l cité vous étiez récemment fait un
grand pas
c'est irresponsable de la communication
cette expérience vous a aidé pour créer
cette école
bien sûr puisque en fait je suis dans la
dynamique d'intelligence économique
depuis à peu près 20 ans et lorsque je
dirigeais la communication de disneyland
j'ai eu des besoins l'adversité confirmé
palcy fait part d'un grand parc
d'attraction dans l'est parisien
remarquable parce que il faut éviter de
par exemple de se faire piquer des idées
de nouvelles animations etc où il ya des
choses comme ça qu'il ya surtout le fait
de considérer l'information comme une
matière première pour laquelle je vais
investir pour essayer de la collecter
n'est pas aussi un peu de paranoïa de la
part des grands groupes aussi
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment qu'on va
tous n'ont volé tout de suite mal
malheureusement on a régressé
oui on a dépassé la pana la paranoïa si
vous êtes paranoïa donc vous êtes en
retard
malheureusement très en retard les
exemples de groupes qui se sont fait
voler des idées des brevets des choses
malheureusement malheureusement c'est
tous les jours et c'est dans des ports
pression y est incroyable totalement
incroyable
tout simplement parce que nous n'avons
pas nous les bons réflexes de protection
d'informations et donc on en laisse
traîner beaucoup plus et vous avez en
face des gens dont aujourd'hui c'est
devenu le métier de voler de
l'information c'est leur métier comme
vous avez vous un métier j'en ai un
leur métier c'est de voler de
l'information malheureusement ça
explique l'explosion
et quel que soit le pays aussi parce que
ce sont plutôt les pays asiatiques qui
regarde ce qui se passe en occident on
va dire où est ce que c'est caricatural
alors c'est caricatural c'est toujours
pratique de dire que globalement c'est
les chinois un lâche jean marc les
chinois les japonais etc
les dernières grandes affaires sont des
affaires totalement intra européennes
malheureusement il faut pas aller
chercher traque au sein même de l'europe
les entreprises utilisent ce genre de
procédé pour vous donner un exemple
clair tout ce qui est délinquance
nouvelles cyber délinquants ont donc la
délinquance par internet arrive
globalement d'europe du centre c'est là
qu'ils sont les gens très fort vous avez
donc créer cette école il ya sept ans
environ et puis à côté vous intervenez
aussi à l'extérieur comme devant ce
groupe d'acteurs économiques de saint
cyr c'était la semaine dernière on y
était on regarde ensemble ce reportage
tisser du lien avec les entreprises du
canton de saint cyr deuxième réunion du
tout nouveau club des entrepreneurs de
saint-cyr-l'ecole groupe créé à
l'initiative de la mairie
objectif rassembler les différents
acteurs économiques de la ville autour
de thèmes d'actualité ce soir
l'intervention porte sur l'intelligence
économique
l'idée c'est aussi de pouvoir offrir une
thématique qui soit transversale et
qu'ils puissent être audible écoutable
et qui puisse servir tant à
l'entrepreneur commerçants qu'à la
petite entreprise dit fait déjà de la
crise du fait qu'on sait pas trop à qui
s'adressait commence vers koné
c'est pour ça que les petits déjeuners
ou des afterwork organisée par le maire
peuvent peut-être nous apporter plein de
choses mais le groupe compte une
quarantaine de membres installés sur les
communes de saint cyr fontenay et bois
d'arcy pour en faire partie
il suffit de s'inscrire gratuitement à
la mairie de saint cyr pour recevoir le
programme des événements
benoît de saint sernin vous voyez
intervenir là devant des acteurs
économiques dont qui ont peut-être une
connaissance de ce qu'est l'intelligence
économique est ce que c'était le cas
cette question c'était le cas
principalement sur le premier volet qui
est toute la notion de protection
mais pour vous donner un dernier exemple
sur l' influence en ce moment la ville
de versailles le département pousse un
projet qui s'appelle la cité de la
gastronomie on est parfaitement en
intelligence économique sur le troisième
volet qu'on appelle l' influence qui
était la notoriété si vous voulez et l'
influence si on réussit à décrocher 100
on est vraiment dans une démarche
d'intelligence économique nous en
parlerons d'ailleurs de cette cité de la
gastronomie qui pourraient se préparer
du côté de versailles ce sera sur le
plateau mardi à 18h en direct
merci beaucoup mena de saint sernin
advenu en plateau pour nous parler de
votre école
merci merci j'en sais maintenant plus
voilà ce qui me concerne sur
l'intelligence économique